[موسيقى]
تشبه طبقه قمر صناعي لكنها اله طبخ
المقعره تستخدم المرايا لتركيز ضوء الشمس
على نقطه مركزيه عندما يتعلق الامر بالطهي
فهو شكل رخيص للغايه من الطاقه الشمسيه
اما افران الحطب فهي اعلى تكلفه واكثر
ضررا
هذا الطباخ جيد جدا منذ ان حصلت عليه
توقفت عن استخدام الحطب ينبعث الدخان من
الحطب ولكن عندما استخدم الموقد الشمسي
ليس هناك دخان واتنفس الهواء النقي يشكل
دخان الحطب خطوره على التنفس هذا الطباخ
جيد لاننا توقفنا عن قطع الاشجار للحصول
على الحطب
في يناير كانون الثاني اوضحت دراسه اجراها
المعهد الملكي للتكنولوجيا في ستوكهولم
انه يمكن انقاذ نصف مليون شخص كل عام في
دول افريقيا جنوب الصحراء اذا عثر على
بدائل للحطب يحتوي دخان الحطب او الفحم
على مزيج معقد من غازات وجزيئات دقيقه
تسبب التهاب الرئتين ويربط خبرائه افران
الحطب بالسرطان
هذا الجهاز ذو اهميه خاصه
التي نجت من سرطان الثدي تعيش وانجيكو وهي
ام لاربعه اطفال في قريه بمقاطعه مورانجا
وسط كينيا وتعتقد ان هذا الطباخ هو
الطريقه الاكثر سهوله للوصول الى طاقه
نظيفه تصنع النساء والمواقد الشمسيه هنا
في مقاطعه مورانجا تقوم النسوه اولا بخلط
الاسمنت المعبا فوق شبكه معدنيه وبعد ذلك
تغطى كامل المنطقه داخل الاناء المقعر
بفسيف سائل من المرايا اللامعه تلتقط
المرايا الحراره من اشعه الشمس
طباخ مرنون لتمكينه من التحرك اثناء دوران
الشمس اما الاواني فسوداء اللون لامتصاص
اكبر قدر ممكن من الحراره اما عن ضرر حرق
الاخشاب والفحم بالصحه فيشرحه هذا المختص
سواء
فيما يتعلق بالسرطان فقد تم ربطه بشكل
اساسي ببعض امراض الجهاز التنفسي لاسيما
سرطان الرئه فقد اظهرت دراسه اجريت اخيرا
في الولايات المتحده وجود ارتباط بين هذه
الغازات المسببه لاحتباس الحراري وسرطان
الرئه وايضا الثدي وحتى في حالات سرطان
الاطفال
الفوائد البيئيه للطهي بهذه الطريقه مهمه
ايضا لجميع النساء هنا لاسيما ان قارتهن
افريقيا تان تحت تاثير تغير المناخ وغازات
الاحتباس الحراري التي ادت الى انعدام
الام الغذائي في بعض مناطقها